represalias por una aplastante
contraofensiva la reafirmación de kiev
en la región de hard kiss ha sido el
mayor revés para los militares rusos
desde que fueron expulsados de la
capital al inicio de la guerra las
fuerzas aeroespaciales rusas así como
las fuerzas de cohetes y artillería
están llevando a cabo ataques masivos en
todas las direcciones operativas contra
unidades del ejército ucraniano al
parecer rusia ha perdido unos 4000
kilómetros cuadrados que estaban bajo su
control es un rápido y eficaz
contraataque en la región esta semana
pasada
el ejército ruso dejó detrás munición y
equipamiento el kremlin afirma que las
fuerzas de kiev han abusado de los
civiles de las zonas que han recapturado
sin embargo los residentes han dicho lo
contrario y ucrania está decidida a
seguir avanzando
el objetivo es liberar completamente la
región de jarquín y otros territorios
ocupados por la federación rusa
esta operación defensiva pretendía
romper las fuerzas enemigas y avanzar
esto se logró y dado el éxito se ha
decidido continuar la operación
en rusia las pérdidas han provocado
algunas críticas a la guerra de putin
mientras que otros han atribuido las
retiradas al suministro de armas
occidentales para ucrania